[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique en plein dans l'actualité de
cette semaine marquée par le congrès des
maires de france
des mères remonté contre les réformes et
les projets d'économie pour comprendre
les raisons de ce malaise quatre invités
sur notre plateau vincent chauvet
bonjour bonjour vous êtes maire d'autun
en saône-et-loire modem république en
marche
nathalie koenders bonjour jai ho ligue 1
mais la première adjointe au maire à
dijon ps ludovic rochette
bonjour président des maires de
côte-d'or et lui les républicains et
vous êtes maire de brognon comme de
côte-d'or et jean-françois farenc
bonjour dangereux président des maires
ruraux de saône-et-loire maire de blanot
communes rurales bonjour à vous en
préparant cette émission je me disais
avec elle est un peu d'ironie que soit
c'est nous qui n'avons pas d'imagination
je vous le concède soit c'est une
dépression qui dure chez vous les maires
parce que c'est un thème des missions
contre étant à peu près tous les ans on
va essayer de comprendre pourquoi
avec une nouveauté cette semaine et
cette année c'était jeudi le président
qui accueille 1500 maires à l'elysée on
dit souvent qu'en politique comme en
amour il faut des preuves alors ludovic
rochette est ce que c'était une preuve
d'amour du président vous y étiez
ou est-ce que c'était comme l'a dit le
maire de saint-etienne à dîner de cons
c'est bien un amour fou de la constance
et si l'histoire d'amour a commencé
depuis son élection elle est quand même
assez tôt montait avec un printemps qui
était plutôt sous de bons auspices on a
passé quand même un été qui était vraie
douche froide pour les collectivités et
puis là on sent que le président tente
de reprendre un lien de confiance mais
ce lien il est vraiment très très
fragile aujourd'hui donc on va voir dans
la durée pour que voir si l'idylle
existe ou si au contraire on commence
par un divorce
votre voisin vous avez câlinothérapie
c'était un symbole d'accueillir tous ces
maires à l'elysée s'était jamais fait je
pense que c'était un symbole de
reconnaître l'importance des élus locaux
dans la mise en oeuvre des politiques
est effectivement ensuite lors du
discours devant la plénière du congrès
des maires
le présent la république a reconnu que
l'épisode estival avait été un peu
chaotique mais que sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat et avoir un pacte de
confiance qui se caractérise par la fin
de la baisse des dotations je pense
qu'on y reviendra et une co-construction
qui a peut-être démarrer cet été sur des
bases un peu fragile mais je suis
confiant sur le fait que le gouvernement
ait l'intention de travailler main dans
la main avec les maires jean-françois
farenc on sait que beaucoup de maires
suivi et de maires ruraux aussi était
très remonté avant cet épisode
et quand vous entendez vendredi matin
françois baroin président des maires de
france déclaré en parlant d' emmanuel
macron il a le bénéfice du doute il ya
la volonté d'avancer ensemble
vous vous êtes déçu vous auriez voulu on
va dire que la résistance soit plus
forte
écoutez il traîne dans l'esprit des
maires ruraux un très grand malaise du
puits depuis plusieurs années kelly est
donc à différentes choses une perte de
confiance mais je dois reconnaître je
les ai interrogés
je dois reconnaître qu'à l'issue de
cette semaine donc il ya eu la soirée à
l'elysée il ya aussi eu le discours du
président de la république que les mères
qui avaient besoin de considération les
maires ruraux qui avait besoin de
considération
on était ont plutôt apprécié cette
semaine alors je dirais pas qu'ils sont
plongés maintenant dans une très grande
confiance dans une béatitude total mais
il s'est passé quelque chose donc
affaire à suivre
affaire à suivre est la question que
nous posons c'est on a le sentiment
souvent que la technostructure impose
ses projets quels que soient les
changements politiques quelles que
soient les alternances politiques on a
l'impression que les mêmes projets
reviennent sur les questions de
l'intercommunalité par exemple du
transfert de compétences automatique de
la commune vers l'intercommunalité on a
l'impression qu'il ya des projets dans
l'est dans les dents les
technostructures dans l'est dans l'est
dans les ministères qui ressorte quoi
qu'il arrive donc on espère que les
directives présidentielles vont être
suivis on va on va aller sur le fond
nathalie koenders vous vous représentez
grandes villes plus grandes villes de
notre région
c'était quoi les attentes avant ce
congrès pour vous vouliez quoi plus
d'argent de la clarification peut être
une ouverture sur ce qui va pouvoir
venir
c'est vrai qu'on attendait une
clarification et pour avoir écouté
attentivement les discours du président
je trouve que c'est un peu un rendez
vous manqué c'est vrai qu'il ya
certaines inquiétudes des mères
notamment sur leur avenir sur les
efforts que l'on nous demande
aujourd'hui alors que la croissance ne
le justifie pas c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui
sur les douze derniers mois on voit
qu'on a un chiffre de 2%
les efforts on les a on les a produit
effectivement au dernier quinquennat les
collectivités territoriales ont
largement contribué au redressement des
finances publiques et c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est le rapport la cour des
comptes didier migaud était présent à
dijon vendredi et il l'a souligné et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'ils aient bien
on estime qu'avec cette croissance qui
repart et bien voilà on demande encore
des défauts aux collectivités
territoriales et dans le discours est
bien il ya des questions où on n'a pas
eu de réponse puisque et sur les emplois
aidés sur le logement social
finalement ça a été pas très clair voilà
donc on est assez déçu de ce discours le
paradoxe c'est que après cette hand
alors on va déjà définir un acronyme la
dgf pour ceux qui nous regardent
dotation de fonctionnement là pour faire
simple l'argent que l'état donne aux
communes après sept ans de baisse
continue de cette dgf
elle est stable dans le prochain budget
et il y avait une opposition annoncé des
maires de france alors que c'était la
première année
finalement la dotation lbl baisse plus
ludovic rochette vous êtes content parce
que vous ne parlez que d'une dotation la
dot la dgf n'est qu'une dotation de
fonctionnement et si on prend l'ensemble
des dotations genre dans le domaine du
sport par exemple dans le domaine des
agences de bassin dans le domaine de
l'eau on s'aperçoit que ce sont des
dotations qui sont loin d'être les dire
qu'il ya dedans et 10 chapitres en fait
bien sûr partie d'argent que les de la
mer e
et puis et puis en même temps toutes les
communes les communes rurales
principalement reprennent l'instruction
des documents d'urbanisme et et des
autorisations d'urbanisme qui a été fait
par l'état donc dire qu'il n' stabilité
c'est faux c'est qu'il ya des transferts
qui se font et des dotations qui sont à
la baisse certes la dgf est maintenu par
contre il faut il faudrait que l'on
s'extasie 2 se maintient on a quand même
eu avec le précédent quinquennat une
baisse comme on n'a jamais vu au nez
avait commencé à aller commencer son le
quinquennat qui avait commencé par
j'ai commencé par être gelée et 110 on
est d'accord que ce soit sous sarkozy
que ce soit donc finalement lourds
devraient tous être d'accord puisque
droite et gauche ont décidé de baisser
les dotations donc ici vous représenter
la droite et la gauche d'aurier tous est
content ah non alors là peut-être pour
pour la dotation globale de
fonctionnement effectivement il ya eu un
engagement qu'elle soit maintenue donc
ça on l'acte c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle mais en même temps pour
reprendre une expression chère à notre
président on va nous demander sur les
cinq prochaines années de faire un
effort de 13 milliards d'euros
d'ailleurs c'est pas non plus très clair
alors on nous dit c'est en fonction des
dépenses des choses comme ça donc voilà
on nous maintient quelque chose mais en
fait une ville comme dijon une
agglomération comme une métropole comme
dijon fait partie effectivement des plus
grosses collectivités de france à qui
l'état va demander des efforts il faut
savoir que cet effort on les fait depuis
longtemps
peut-être que c'était important
effectivement des collectivités se
remettent en cause et revoient leur
organisation en interne
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne la ville
de dijon il faut savoir que notre masse
salariale représente moins de 50 % des
dépenses de fonctionnement donc il ya
des efforts très importants qui ont été
faits par les agents de la ville devait
l'être fait est ce que ça veut dire à
linverse que pendant longtemps les
apparaît cependant peut-être
qu'effectivement il ya eu ce côté
vertueux où il a fallu que les
collectivités se remette en question
mutualisent les services là dessus je
pense qu'il ya eu peut-être un effet
bénéfique
maintenant aujourd'hui les efforts je ne
vois pas comment on va pouvoir demander
encore plus d'efforts à nos agents il
faut savoir que les efforts qu'on
demande aux collectivités territoriales
c'est aussi les contribuables qui vont
les faire parce que derrière c'est le
service public
ces services qu'on apporte au public qui
va un moment donné va peut-être diminué
de par la situation financière actuelle
pour pour ces collectivités
on parle de 1,2 pour cent mais pour la
ville de dijon où la métropole tout
dépendra aussi de l'inflation et avec
une inflation au delà de 1,2 sa soif en
compte un effort très compliqué à faire
pour les collectivités je pense qu'ils
font remettre dans un vrai contexte
économique global il faut voir l'état de
la france qui d'une certaine manière et
le résultat de trente ans de politique
des partis classiques de droite des
partis classiques de bouche
aujourd'hui la croissance revient
faiblement c'est aussi le résultat d'une
politique économique volontariste du
président de la république mais on est à
100 % de dette sur le produit intérieur
brut
donc ça
photo pour desserrer l'étau on doit
redescendre sous la barre des 3% de
déficit annuel et on doit absolument
revenir à un stock de dette soutenable
aujourd'hui la france est en quasi
faillite elle l'est déjà depuis
plusieurs plusieurs années ça suppose
que tout le monde prenne sa part de
l'effort il y avait une solution très
simple qui a expliqué le précédent
gouvernement socialiste s'était de
couper à la hache et de baisser d'année
en année les dotations le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe et emmanuel macron a
décidé quelque chose de plus compliqué
et en même temps peut-être plus
intelligent de dire on va maintenir les
dotations mais on va demander
effectivement des efforts ciblés on va
demander un effort sur l'augmentation
l'inflation des dépenses il faudra aller
moins vite que l'inflation donc oui on
continue à demander des efforts
importants aux collectivités on cible
aussi ce qu'on appelle les dodus
dormants c'est à dire les organismes
publics éventuellement les organismes
publics locaux qui ont un peu de
trésorerie et qui peuvent exemple
justement certains offices hlm par
exemple les agences de l'eau c'était le
mot que je vous les agences de l'eau
certains et et là où le gouvernement
fait quelque chose qui n'a pas été fait
c'est que au lieu d'avoir une politique
un peu stupide de baisses drastiques de
dépenses on va regarder et on va toucher
au tabou de ce qu'on a jamais fait la
politique du logement il y aura une
grande réforme
la politique de la fiscalité locale le
gouvernement a annoncé en 2020 une
refonte parce que là on parle entre nous
on comprend à peu près les acronymes
mais quand vous rentrez dans le détail
des dotations globales de fonctionnement
restent à l'investissement la des
notaires etc
je défie quiconque de trouver une
personne en france on a peut-être une ou
deux qui comprend parfaitement et
maîtrise l'ensemble de la mécanique j'ai
fait rêver là j'espère que non - qui
sait comment ça marche non mais la
complexité est délirant soir justement
on ira vers une règlement global les
services à la france elle est
potentiellement faillite
on est bien obligés de faire des
économies je pense que les l'emea fondé
cet argument l'aurait laissé entendre
c'est cet argument est entendu par les
maires ce soit les maires des villes où
les maires ruraux
bien évidemment il faut participer à
l'effort de réduction des dépenses
publiques qui n'est pas achevée malgré
ce qui a été fait ce qui nous plaît
quand même nous mais ruraux dans la
démarche qui est engagée c'est qu'on a
reconnu que les communes rurales sont à
loos si vous voulez vous c'est pas vous
qui était plus visés par les réformes en
comme les mesures pour écouter sur les
skis et enfin les communes rurales ne
participeront pas on reconnaît qu' un
très gros effort a été fait savez la
dotation de fonctionnement
prenez une commune de 2 100 2 20 et 2
200 habitants s'étaient 30000 euros
aujourd'hui elle est inférieure à 20
milles en général donc vous quand vous
avez de dix douze mille euros de moins
sur un budget d'une commune rurale qui
fait deux cent mille euros
quand vous êtes à 200 habitants c'est à
peu près ça c'est énorme c'est énorme
mais qu'est ce que vous avez dans ces
communes
un employé ou deux employés vous pouvez
pas tailler dans les services vous
pouvez rayer éventuellement réduire
quelques heures supplémentaires ou des
choses comme ça donc voilà les communes
rurales sont plutôt satisfaites
l'association des maires ruraux est
plutôt satisfaite de de ce coup d'arrêt
qui est mis pour les sur les économies
dans les petites communes rurales
il ya un mot qui parcourt tout ce débat
c'est la taxe d'habitation
avec cette réforme avec un paradoxe on a
entendu beaucoup de choses très très
philosophique sur le fonctionnement des
collectivités sur ce que ça va changer
et finalement on entend on n'a pas
entendu beaucoup de mères pendant ce
congrès des maires dire ben même temps
c'est quand même bien parce qu'il ya des
gens qui vont payer moins d'impôts corps
ont un pouvoir d'achat en hausse
c'est quand même le paradoxe de est ce
que ça vous semble bien cette réforme
nathalie koenders
ou est-ce que vous voyez sur tout
l'argent que peut-être vous ne toucherez
plus que la ville de dijon touchera plus
c'est un engagement qui avait pris le
président de la république donc il le
tient
c'est vrai que on estime pour beaucoup
que c'était pas forcément un impôt juste
socialement puisque déjà une partie de
la population ne la paient déjà pas et
puis ensuite alors là on rentre vraiment
dans l'aspect technique mais il y avait
les bases locatives à revoir et en
fonction des quartiers
ce n'était pas très juste donc c'est un
fait et elle va être supprimée c'est une
bonne chose pour les contribuables pour
autant moi j'ai ça me pose deux
questions la première c'est alors l'état
va faire ne va pas compenser m'évader
gréve et donc ça permettra effectivement
aux collectivités territoriales de
recevoir la même somme d'argent mais
pour combien de temps et puis la
deuxième chose c'est un moment un impôt
qui est payé par seulement 20% de la
population n'est pas forcément un bon
impôts donc c'est à terme d'accueil soit
parce qu'il a laissé entendre après vous
savez les gens ne sont pas dupes
un moment quand supprimer un impôt il va
bien falloir le recréer un nouvel un pur
à côté on sera vigilant parce que si
c'est pour supprimer d'un côté et
refaire un impôt et puis enfin on va
c'est encore une perte d'autonomie
fiscale de la part des collectivités
territoriales qui vont encore plus être
sous tutelle de l'état
maintenant juste je voudrais répondre
par rapport au logement social par
rapport à l'exemple que vous avez pris
effectivement il ya des offices
peut-être on appelle avec des doses
dodus dormants avec des trésoreries qui
n'investit sais pas et là effectivement
on n'est pas d'accord il faut les taxer
mais je vais prendre l'exemple de grand
dijon habitat qui n'est pas dans cet ex
dans ce cas de figure et qui avait prévu
par exemple l'année prochaine d'investir
3,6 millions d'années pour rénover son
parc social pour faire de la rénovation
énergétique pour construire et
finalement et bien l'état va prendre ses
3,6 millions d'euros pour compenser la
baisse des apl et ben concrètement ça
veut dire que dijon gravitas ne pourra
pas investir donc qui va payer ce nom
investissement c'est déjà les locataires
parce que c'est la rénovation
énergétique qui se fera pas et c'est en
même temps les entreprises locales les
artisans qui vont perdre de la commande
publique dont l'art donnez moi si on
élargit est-ce que ce que vous décrivez
sur les offices hlm
ce serait une émission en elle même
mais parler des bassins la gestion de
l'eau est ce qu'on n'est pas dans des
couches empilées depuis un siècle dans
le fonctionnement des collectivités
françaises avec la création de toutes
ces superstructures et est ce que
finalement ce que le président de la
république commence à faire c'est pas
vouloir remettre tout ça à plat cassé
tous à ludovic rochette est ce que les
offices hlm qui issus des départements
issus des vides enfin on sait qu'il y en
a beaucoup en france parfois en
situation de concurrence c'est un
exemple est ce qu'il n'est pas temps de
revoir tout ça l'inquiétude que même
aujourd'hui c'est que avec cette
question de la taxe d'habitation que ce
soit 80 % à 100 %
ça va être l'élargissement de la
fracture territoriale
ça va être une part de communes qui vont
pouvoir s'en sortir parce que les
populations sont aisés
parce que il ya des revenus annexes et
puis à côté de ça se comprend parce si
c'est qu'on pensait à nanan vous voyez
la différence alors expliqué oui parce
que la grande différence c'est que on va
voir des communes qui vont avoir des
marges pour trouver d'autres ressources
on voir des communes qui vont en fin de
compte avoir eu un budget qui va être
complètement gelé par l'état je pense
qu'on le problème a été pris à l'envers
c'est qu'on est tous d'accord pour
réformer la fiscalité locale
on est tous d'accord pour dire que le
système il est au bout on est bien sûr
volontaires d'accompagner le président
dans ses réformes
par contre en prenant le problème à
l'envers eh bien on va accroître les
inégalités territoriales
c'est là où la mf au niveau national et
bien souhaite que la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation apporte à la fin et bien eu
une autre fiscalité faut qu'on imagine
ça a été plus ou moins annoncé une
réforme et une fiscalité issus du local
n'est pas décidée par l'état
et ça c'est paris pas indispensable pour
que les territoires puissent continuer
c'est une c'est une perte d'autonomie
quand même vous perdez la taxe
d'habitation et communes pouvaient jouer
sur les taux les réduire
exceptionnellement les augmenté parfois
là vous perdez une ressource fiscale
sous maîtrise communal au bénéfice d'une
compensation qui qui va ressembler à une
dotation
voilà donc ensuite on dit dans trois ans
d'ici trois ans on essaiera peut-être de
mettre un impôt local à la place de
cette taxe d'habitation qui a disparu
bon je veux bien je pense ça va être
compliqué quand même de recréer un impôt
nouveau dans les trois ans qui viennent
l'instant une grande référence ça va
mais déjà ça sera pas simple moi je
pense qu'il faut remettre cette réforme
dans la philosophie globale du
gouvernement
on va pas recréer une taxe puisque
l'objectif c'est de baisser le niveau
des dépenses publiques on avait une
dette publique importante on avait une
pression fiscale importante parce qu'on
dépense trop en france
par ailleurs la taxe d'habitation c'est
un petit rendement mais c'est un impôt
extrêmement injuste quand vous êtes à
paris vous payer quasiment pas de taxes
d'habitation dans certaines communes
rurales vous payez pas de taxe
d'habitation et c'est tout sur les mêmes
la réforme là est intéressante parce que
80 % des ménages les plus aisés dans la
ville d'autun dont je suis le maire ça
va aller jusqu'à 86 % des ménages donc
le 86 % des ménages ne payeront plus
aucune taxe d'habitation et donc on sera
sur quelque chose d'intéressant
et justement va revenir au 14 mai 14 %
vont garder le même le même le même
impôt et ses 2.5 millions d'euros 2,5
millions d'euros qui reviendront dans la
poche des contribuables autunois et qui
seront réinvestis
justement dans le commerce local par
exemple c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on rétabli au contraire on
rétablit une égalité de traitement entre
les habitants de paris de la province
des villes des centres villes et des
campagnes est par ailleurs effectivement
on va vers une simplification à terme je
souhaite également la fin d'un taxe
d'habitation et qu'on simplifie touche
maquis fiscal parce que je leur ai dit
effectivement sur l'autonomie on sait
plus qui vote quoi quel taux le
département la région
les gens ne voient rien sur leur feuille
d'impôt c'est le maire qui est tout le
temps responsable à la fin si ça
augmente ou si sa baisse qu'on remette
chacun dans ses compétences
le maire voit remettre chacun d'un cycle
et les tensions avec chacun des
ressources clair qu'elles viennent de
l'état ou des taxes et qu'on en finisse
avec ses responsabilités croisé qui font
qu'à la faim plus personne n'est
responsable de rien les impôts
augmentent et nos centres villes sont en
difficulté par coup de poing pour
l'inégalité fiscale inégalités fiscales
existent au sein d'une même commune au
sein du même commune suivant la date de
construction du bâtiment mais
l'inégalité fiscale c'est aussi le
foncier bâti soit s'il faut
le bâti c'est la cotisation foncière sur
les entreprises donc si on veut cet à
katyn galfond et où on attaque tout en
attaque on commence par ça et on ne
cible pas au départ une seule taxe
ludovic rochette et j'en ai tout le
monde si je vous dis avec un peu
d'humour que ans finalement une partie
de la droite était pas très à l'aise
dans ce congrès parce que d'un côté elle
défend les maires mais qu'elle est
plutôt favorable aux réformes proposées
par emmanuel macron en fait on vous sent
pas dans une opposition hyper frontale
aux mesures c'est on est déjà dans un
temps qui a changé avec des rapports de
force qui ont changé sa parole il n'a
pas à déclencher mai mais oh je suis
assez surpris par votre question parce
que notre débat aujourd'hui c'est bien
de montrer que mais il ya quand même un
clivage sur cette question de la
fiscalité locale
à côté de ça il ya des courses ont su
généraux sur sur des récents seraient
ouverts nuage entre vous moi je ne sens
pas vraiment clivage la taxe
d'habitation est à peu près tous
d'accord pour dire qu'elle est injuste
et donc il faut la réformer
on a peut-être des clivages ceux déjà
sur le passé sur le fait qu' on a géré
je mal équipe qu'on attendait on a
demandé aux collectivités un effort que
l'état ne sait pas assumer à lui-même et
que si aujourd'hui il ya des efforts sur
les comptes publics
ce sont les collectivités c'est pas
forcément l'état moi je suis dans le
présent décret est lui passé mais voilà
je suis dans le présent et dans le futur
nous ce qu'on ce qu'on dit aussi c'est
effectivement les collectivités ont fait
de nombreux efforts on leur en demande
encore alors que la croissance ne
justifie pas et que l'état quand vous
regardez le projet de loi de finances
pour 2010 8 ne va pas se laisser imposer
non plus puisque il est prévu un déficit
de 13 milliards donc c'est à dire
pourquoi demander des efforts importants
collectivités encore plus l'année
prochaine alors que la croissance repart
et que et permettez-moi la croissance
repart aussi grâce au quinquennat
précédent
emmanuel macron a dit je serai jugé sur
les réformes que je fais dans un ou deux
ans donc permettez moi de dire que si la
croissance repart c'est aussi grâce au
travail qui a été fait même s'il ya la
confiance est ce qu'on demande
voilà c'est aussi que l'état s'applique
ses efforts à lui même est ce le projet
de loi de finances 2010 8 ne le démontre
pas
revient sous les 3% on respecte nos
engagements européens à ce qu'on ne
faisait pas depuis
même avant la crise de 2008 donc l'état
aussi prend sa part de responsabilité
mais tout le monde doit prendre sympa et
ce n'est pas au moment où la croissance
repas qu'on doit dire justement à dans
ses films des réformes c'est justement
quand on on a un climat favorable c'est
plus facile de faire des réformes
quand ça repart que de faire ce qu'on a
fait pendant la crise où c'est l'ultime
round question l'attention enfin chez
les maires ruraux en tout cas chez tous
ceux que j'ai rencontrés et plutôt
retombé à l'issue de cette de cette
semaine pour répondre à votre question
il ya le climat est plutôt plus
favorable maintenant évidemment le
gouvernement est en temps est attendu
aux actes et je voudrais reprendre ce
que je disais tout à l'heure au début
nous avons parfois l'impression que
l'administration par exemple sur ces
questions de transfert de compétences ou
tout ça ressort systématiquement ses
projets donc ce que l'on attend c'est un
véritable poids du politique du
gouvernement des ministres sur leur
administration pour que ne rejaillisse
pas les vieilles lunes là qui sortent
régulièrement et nous avons des doutes
là dessus et je fais une proposition
nous faisons l'union des maires ruraux
de saône et loire une proposition au
préfet s'il faut faire des propositions
aussi c'est que pour améliorer le
fonctionnement de la haute fonction
publique c'est que les stagiaires et non
il ya toujours des stagiaires henin à la
préfecture de saône et loire comme dans
les autres puissent faire un stage de
quinze jours dans nos communes rurales
j'ai écrit au préfet sur ce sujet et je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui pourra
participer plus générale où il suit à st
si ça marche on évoquait tout à l'heure
peut-être une réforme de d'un certain
nombre de structures s qui a pas et
c'est ce qu'on sent dans quand les mères
parlent de leur expérience de leur vie
quotidienne de la difficulté aujourd'hui
de le remplir escape a aussi un besoin à
la fois de reconnaissance de statut et
peut-être de révolution dans les têtes
moi je me souviens d'une expression
pendant les élections législatives à
propos quand on parlait de la réserve
parlementaire qui était il y en a marre
de faire les mendiants est ce que les
maires ont ce qu'on n'a pas obliger un
moment donné les maires à aller chercher
des subventions à aller les chercher
auprès des députés aller les chercher
auprès des conseils départementaux qui
quand même publié
gliese de toutes les communes qu'ils ont
gentiment aider mais on sent bien le
lien de suggestions qui se crée là
dedans
est-ce que vous élus de petites ou
grandes communes vous aimeriez pas avoir
une forme d'indépendance nouvelles ou de
reconnaissance nouvelle je dirais pas
forcément liens de sujétion ou de
hiérarchie mais on perd un temps fou et
du temps de cerveau et de l'argent aller
chercher des subventions à des échelons
différents
l'idée c'était justement avec la
décentralisation que les communes soient
en charge de par exemple les écoles
primaires les collèges les départements
les régions les lycées pour faire simple
et les compétences économiques les
régions et qu'on le social les
départements c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui où le département
finance n'importe quoi
la région finance des petits bouts à
droite à gauche on est toujours content
de recevoir des subventions mais les
subventions croisées nom et le fait que
tout le monde s'occupe de tout ça nuit à
la clarté et à l'action publique le
maire ailleurs je reste conseiller
départemental mariage il ya les lois
notre que j'ai combattu mais qui au
moins aujourd'hui est bien dit ce que
chacun fait donc le département la
région ne peuvent plus faire n'importe
quoi ces cibles et avec des champs de
compétence quoi vous faites quand vous
faites un projet vous construisez un une
place pour rénover une place vous avez
de l'argent de la région via l'europe où
la région elle même parfois du
département de la commune de la commune
de l'état via la dotation des
territoires ruraux
c'est du n'importe quoi nous passons des
heures et des heures à monter des
dossiers lui mentant dans un projet
important bon faut quatre ou cinq
sources de subventions effectivement et
à tous les niveaux bon il ya les
réserves de parlementaires tout ce qui
vient de s'en aller mais et c'est pas
normal on pourrait faire on peut faire
plus simple manqué deux ou trois sources
la région le département c'est
imaginable mais il ya trop de le système
est un institutionnel et notamment toute
la question des syndicats des pays est
sans doute à simplifier les régions
pourraient travailler directement avec
les communautés de communes
ça ferait déjà les babines en allant un
peu plus loin il faut une clarification
là dessus alors on a compris qu'il ya
même une réforme constitutionnelle qui
se prépare éventuellement pour pour
simplifier tout ça ce rapport aussi avec
le on sent qu'avec l'état il nous reste
deux minutes d'émission nous allons les
deux nous dire qu'on sent qu'il est en
ce qu'il faut simplifier l'eau
l'assainissement sont des compétences
fondamentales pour l'avenir
et là on a un travail claire de de
simplification par pl ne doivent pas
être
ferrer automatiquement cette compétence
eau assainissement ne doit pas a priori
cette obtenu à suivre il n'est pas
normal que la luano par contre est
prévue en transperçant plus constant
plus vaste % moi je vois que ça fait 60
% quand on aura juste une collectivité
ça m'étonnerait qu'on arrive au même
taux par contre on est d'accord il ya
des choses traînent de simplification
dans les démarches
vous parliez des clivages de marche on
parle aussi des réseaux peut aider voilà
un clivage actuel ce qui serait ce qui
sera une émission complète nathalie
koenders
oui alors il faut qu'elle a vu une
métropole là dessus ce n'est pas une
clarification même si la loi notre et
voilà clarifier un peu sur les
compétences maintenant vous vous dites
qu'il faut peut-être plus d'autonomie
pour les communes mais j'ai l'impression
donc on annonce une réforme fiscale mais
pour l'instant j'ai plus l'impression
que cette autonomie on va la perdre de
parts ce qu'on vient de dire la paire de
la taxe d'habitation qui était une bonne
chose par ailleurs on va nous demander
aussi pour les 360 plus grande commune
d'aller chaque année devant le préfet
pour voir par rapport à toutes les
palmes à l'eau budget si on est derrière
la clochette
donc voilà maintenant des fois c'est
important aussi qui est des financements
croisés parce que quand une métropole
dont dijon construit à zenit une piscine
ça prend ça veut ça profite à l'ensemble
de la population donc il faut à la
porosité entre les connu vous entendez
la musique c'est terminé désolé ce débat
aurait pu durer beaucoup il va durer
encore parce qu'il ya plein de réforme
est en cours
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu
sur notre plateau ce dimanche allez au
passage un grand merci à vous qui nous
regardent et dimanche dernier vous avez
donné à l'émission sur les vins de
bourgogne sont ils un produit de luxe
la meilleure audience de france est la
meilleure de la saison merci encore
au revoir et bon dimanche